cette année 2015 a été très très
intenses pour moi et comme l'année
dernière je vais revenir sur ce que je
fais faire le point comme ça ceux qui ne
suivent pas n'auront plus excuses sa
partie l'année a commencé fort avec la
sortie de mon premier court métrage
technophobes voilà c'était la première
fois pour moi que je racontais une
histoire plus longue avec des
personnages qui évoluent et l'accueil
sur internet et par les médias a été
exceptionnel donc merci beaucoup d'avoir
accueilli chaleureusement c'était
beaucoup de travail mais ça vaut le coup
parce que c'était une histoire je
voulais vraiment raconter et aussi
prendre un petit peu de risque et
montrer autre chose que des vidéos face
cam vraies petites fictions surtout ça
m'a donné envie d'en faire d'en faire
plus j'ai fait mon premier doublage au
cinéma ça c'est vraiment un truc que je
voulais faire depuis que j'étais tout
gamin faire une voie alors c'est une
toute petite voix pour un tout petit
rôle dans bob l'eponge c'est une mouette
mais c'était vraiment génial de donner
vie comme ça si ces petits personnages
et donc j'espère que c'est le début
d'une longue série
donnez moi n'importe quoi une mouette un
caillou qui parle je le fais ça a été
beaucoup demandé et j'ai publié mon gros
my life on dessine ma vie voilà où je
raconte mon enfance d'où je viens d'où
viennent mes parents ça allie un petit
peu mes deux passions se voulait
vraiment faire ce don royal parce que
j'adore le dessin
voilà j'adore raconter mes vielles
également comme ça je n'ai plus aucun
secret pour personne que moi en 6e je
sais j'ai un truc contre les dons parce
qu'elle me dit j'ai mangé sais je sais
tout sur ta vie avec mes potes de
youtube en a fait une vidéo sur avengers
avec un budget exceptionnel de 27
centimes c'était vraiment fun de tout
bricoler comme ça d'imaginer des plans
avec pas grand chose avec des plaques de
plexi des costumes dégueulasse des
petits objets comme j'adore la paix loi
tient d'ailleurs regardez la mienne
comme un des jolis j'ai fait une vidéo
pour la critiquer un petit peu un désolé
apple je ne voulais pas voulu froisser
j'adore vos produits mais là vous êtes
un petit peu fou à chaque fois que je
parle d'un produit j'ai eu le droit dans
les commentaires à points produits
non non parce que je critique le premier
peloton de produits non non j'ai
vraiment apple
oui j'ai appelé un médecin quand même
dans le doute je vais l'appeler tout de
suite ne vous le savez j'ai une marque
de tee shirt qui s'appelle narbonne et
cette année on était au citadium à paris
donc dans un magasin voilà la marque
était présente et c'était superbe de
vous présenter les produits de vous
montrer des dessins que j'ai fait de
vous voir à les essayer d'entendre vos
retours d'ailleurs la légende raconte
que je porterai actuellement un tee
shirt qui sortirait bientôt sur la
boutique marmol voilà pour fêter les 7
millions d'abonnés sur youtube bien que
ça j'ai répondu à vos questions et c'est
là que j'ai découvert que françois
hollande me suivez sur twitter rien que
ça et je me suis pris un énorme vent
puisque huit mois plus tard je n'ai
toujours pas de réponse du président à
mon message privé françois réponds moi
s'il te plaît si tu reviens j'annule
tout pourquoi je parle comme un
allemande angela merkel sort de ce corps
la sortie de mon deuxième court métrage
qui s'appelle le lecteur qui d'ailleurs
est plus une sorte de sketches j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup aimé mettre en scène
et parler aux comédiens voilà leur faire
dire les répliques je sais que c'était
un petit peu osé de faire un truc plus
court dans un seul décor après
technophobes mais c'était vraiment une
histoire je voulais raconter cette
petite bataille de regards qui a glissé
commentaires haineux et tout le monde a
à jouer vraiment bien justin nicolas
catherine
et me ludovic voilà c'était des gens
géniaux et également la grand-mère pour
blic claudette d'études richir direction
los angeles pour le salon du jeu vidéo
cette année j'étais accompagné du petit
lucas hochart relate a fait ses premiers
pas à los angeles pour la salon du jeu
vidéo 6 après avoir foulé moi ça fait
maintenant plusieurs années et je vais
aller maintenant tous les ans l'année
prochaine aussi et c'est vraiment une
ambiance de fou parce qu'on peut voir
plein de nouveautés rencontrer plein de
gens tester des jeux en avant première
j'aimerais tellement vous soyez là voilà
vous mettre tout dans ma valise mais on
souhaite chers en supplément bagages on
a fait une petite vidéo sur batman avec
squeeze j'incarne une sorte de bruce
wayne et du courage aux fruits pas cher
qui avoue à ses potes qu'il est batman
mais personne ne veut le croire la
stella c'est assez fou tournage
d'ailleurs le décor c'était un truc de
malade c'était un château qui a servi
aussi pour le tournage du dernier un gay
games sur la deux films au cinéma j'ai
fait et je connais cet endroit mais j'ai
marché par là là où jennifer lawrence a
marché ah oui je me sens plus proche
d'elle ri et j'ai aussi porter un
costume de batman qui a fait suer à peu
près 10 litres d'autre doit se sentir un
peu la morale alors vous parle
l'école deux premiers les tournages de
la rentrée c'était vraiment fun avec
jimmy labo enthousiaste et là je reviens
sortira un bêtisier de ce tournage parce
qu on a fait les cons tout le temps non
sur cycling et nîmes on a eu l'immense
privilège de recevoir shigeru miyamoto
le créateur de zelda de mario et takashi
tezuka le créateur de yoshi d'animal
crossing
ce sont un peu les papas du jeu vidéo on
peut dire ça comme ça et on leur a fait
jouer à un niveau fourbe qu'on a créé
avec squeeze et on s'est bien marré
c'était super intimidant et en même
temps une rencontre exceptionnelle voilà
de jouer avec les darons du jeu vidéo
voilà les piliers de ce que moi je
j'adore dans le jeu vidéo est certes est
vraiment une rencontre exceptionnelle
avec shigeru miyamoto parce que c'est un
grand gamin à 60,3 en mai il avait une
énergie de fugu dès qu'il est arrivé il
a touché tous les objets il a regardé
partout il s'amusait avec n'importe quoi
elle a posé plein de questions c'est un
petit peu un modèle pour moi de création
de ce qu'il a fait est aussi d'énergie
abonnez vous on reste dans le jeu vidéo
avec le cyprien gaming chose de ou
plutôt le squeeze gaming show on a on a
créé une petite histoire un peu marrant
tu vois là où ils l'ont renverse pour
prendre les rênes finalement de la
chaîne cyprien gaming avec ce spectacle
nouveau spectacle a été très très très
nombreux encore plus nombreux que les
dernières à suivre au chaud et ça ne
sommes pas extrêmement plaisir ça fait
toujours bizarre vous voir en vrai comme
ça dans une salle ça ça nous touche
énormément et même en ligne parce que
oui c'était retransmis en ligne en
direct sur youtube rapidement et plus
généralement sur la chaîne cyprien
gamine on a vécu plein de supers moments
bas à los angeles que tak mais aussi des
live avec vannes start son passé plein
de jeux et beaucoup d'amusement des
poteaux tout ça et l'année prochaine on
va faire encore plein de choses en
parlant de se rencontrer en vrai on
était à la paris games week cette année
la dernière aussi l'année prochaine on
sera aussi présent on était sur la scène
de la coupe du monde du jeu vidéo
ça fait bizarre de jouer face à 5000
personnes certes un petit peu la
pression et à chaque fois que j'ai la
pression je perds j'ai perdu devant 5000
personnes soit fait très plaisir
j'adore sa voix à waimes faire humilier
j'adore ça l'humiliation
j'étais présent la vidéo city paris
c'est un petit peu le salon des youtuber
voilà j'ai pu faire le con sur scène
faire des dédicaces avec vous touchez un
petit peu comme ça pour voir si vous
êtes bien vrai et j'ai aussi rencontré
plein de créateurs du net donc c'était
super intéressant de rencontrer d'autres
youtuber de discuter de comment créer
comment on peut collaborer aussi y voir
des petites surprises j'y retourne là
l'année prochaine
donc n'hésitez pas à venir pourra
revenir dix huit millions d'abonnés dit
vidéo spéciale et là j'ai testé des
objets chelou que j'ai trouvé sur
internet comme par exemple un objet que
j'ai oublié de déballer un objet pour
taper des mains bon si les japonais
ça fait un an et demi que je travaillais
en presque secret sur ma bd roger et
c'est humain est sorti alors ça a été en
rupture de stock très rapidement si vous
êtes des fous à tout acheter c'est enfin
de retour disponible voilà si vous
voulez avoir un petit roger c'est
possible désormais ça a été un coup de
travail va pas se mentir beaucoup des
changes entre l'éditrice le destinateur
la coloriste pour enfin arriver à ça si
vous avez l'occasion de la guerre vous
verrez qu'il ya un petit peu tout
l'univers reconnaîtrait un petit peu
l'une avec des nouveaux personnages qui
sont assez étonnants j'espère que je
travaille déjà sur sur le tome 2 ça veut
dire beaucoup pour moi et quand j'étais
gamin je pensais pas pouvoir sortir une
bd un jouet en fait à tout ce qui se
passe dans ma vie grâce à vous la plein
de choses qui peuvent être possibles et
du coup le ballon unique lien qui a huit
ans il rêvait de truquer le site
week-end à 26 et les réalise je suis
parti à londres
une journée pour aller dans un cimetière
pour surtout le tournage de you tube
rewind 2015 donc c'est un peu la compil
avec plein de youtube heures d'un petit
peu partout dans le monde
sur un fond musical de faire une petite
vidéo buzz l'alizé par youtube l'année
dernière j'étais déjà présent dans le
youtube ray wang 2014 qui a fait quand
même 100 millions de vues je pense que
je suis un peu pour quelques chemins non
non comme chaque année youtube a établi
son classement des vidéos les plus vues
en fonction des pays et dans la
catégorie non clip musical c'est
technophobes qui arrive en premier c'est
vraiment mortel parce que c'est une
vidéo qui compte beaucoup pour moi et
qu'elle soit la première comme ça du
classement c'est ça ça me touche
beaucoup et donc merci à vous les
internautes avaient rendu ça possible de
changer rien si vous comptiez changer un
truc ne fait pas et on arrive à la fin
de l'année 2015 et je viens tout juste
de terminer le tournage de mon prochain
court-métrage d'ailleurs pour ça que je
porte un bonnet parce que le personnage
a une prof de merde je veux voilà
c'était sept jours de tournage c'était
super intense parfois c'était un peu
galère mais la plupart du temps c'était
vraiment fun on s'est vraiment amusé et
moi j'ai adoré ce moment là et j'ai hâte
vous montrer ça il ya encore beaucoup de
boulot parce que ça doit partir en
montage composition des musiques knicks
son étalonnage effets spéciaux sortira
pas avant fin janvier et encore beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de boulot je vais m'y
atteler deux pas et j'espère que ça va
vous plaire et j'ai encore plein
d'autres histoires et plein d'autres
personnages à vous montrer dans d'autres
vidéos donc rester pas loin sur internet
et voilà c'était les grands points de
mon année 2015 il ya encore plein de
trucs dont je vous ai pas parlé mais bon
faut pas faire des vidéos de trois
heures en tout cas je pense que je
réalisais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses cette année je pensais pas en
faire autant sur tout et ils sont très
importants pour moi faire du doublage
une bd un court métrage et j'ai aussi
plein pas pleins d'autres surprises pour
l'année prochaine nous réserve plein de
trucs vous permettez de faire des trucs
encore plus ouf
donc merci beaucoup à mai prochain ou
discuter